BRETT SLATKIN: Hey, my name is
Brett Slatkin, and I'm a
software engineer
here at Google.
We're here today to talk about
IndieWebCamp and the
independent web with Tantek
Celik, who's a technologist,
writer and teacher.
He currently is at Mozilla,
focusing on open web standards.
And you may also know him as a
creator of many communities
like BarCamp and Microformats.
You can find Tantek
at tantek.com.
So yeah, let's get into it.
So, Tantek, you recently
won an election.
What was that election about?
TANTEK CELIK: So I recently
ran for the W3C's advisory
board, and that's a board of
about nine people that advise
the W3C on all matters, like
process, running the W3C, all
that kind of thing, and selected
by all the member
companies of the W3C.
BRETT SLATKIN: And this is for
web standards just like HTML
and CSS, and basically
everything that makes up the
internet, the web
as we know it.
TANTEK CELIK: Yeah, so the
advisory board doesn't work on
those standards, but sort of
works on how does the W3C work
at all to create the
groups that then
work on those standards.
BRETT SLATKIN: For governance
and things like that.
TANTEK CELIK: For governance
So a bunch of us had been
pursuing making standards more
open, how they're developed more
open, and ran for the W3C
advisory board on this sort
of platform of openness.
And some of us got elected, and
so now we're going to be
pushing to make the W3C even
more open in how it works.
BRETT SLATKIN: That's great.
So open is very important
to you.
We're talking about the
indie web today.
And maybe some people
don't know.
What is the indie web?
What does the indie web mean?
TANTEK CELIK: So the indie web
is really about people owning
their own content, owning their
identity, owning their
own domain on the web and
controlling it, doing with it
as they please, and using
that as their primary
identity on the web.
And that's sort of in contrast
to creating an account on
somebody else's system and
posting your content on
someone else's site.
BRETT SLATKIN: Great.
So there's also an event that
you helped organize, called
IndieWebCamp.
It's been around for
a few years now.
It started in 2011.
And it's happening next week in
Portland, June 22 and 23.
So tell us about IndieWebCamp.
What is IndieWebCamp
all about?
TANTEK CELIK: So it's all fine
and dandy to create your own
website, but as humans, we build
communities around the
things we have in common.
And the IndieWebCamp really
started as kind of a BarCamp
DevCamp for those of us that are
passionate about the indie
web, creating our presence on
the web, but we wanted to
collaborate, and share our
ideas, and share our code, and
share our designs for doing so,
and hopefully even get our
sites to talk to each other.
And we can get into a little
bit of that later.
BRETT SLATKIN: So what kind of
people go to IndieWebCamp?
TANTEK CELIK: The people that
go to IndieWebCamp--
essentially, you have to be
dedicated to owning your
identity on the web, so you have
to have your own domain
and be like, this is me, this is
who I am on the web, and I
don't mind putting my
stuff out there.
And then you have to be a
creator of some sort, so
whether that's a builder or
developer, like you write
code, or you do user interface
design, or you do graphic
design, or any kind of flow.
Even if you're just a content
author and being an
independent content author is
your thing, you have to be a
creator of some sort.
And then the third quality that
we look for is people
that are willing to freely share
at least some of what
they create so that we can build
on each other's work.
So that's really what
it's about.
You have your own identity
on the web.
You're a creator of some sort.
And then you share
some of what you
create openly and freely.
BRETT SLATKIN: Great.
So what inspired you to pursue
the indie web and start
IndieWebCamp?
TANTEK CELIK: So I've had my own
site for a while, and I've
been blogging since 2002.
And a lot of that, I kind of
slacked off on that myself
with sort of increased use of
Twitter, and Pounce, and lots
of other services--
Flickr.
But one of the things I finally
realized, the more I
used these services, the more
frustrated I got with
different things, and I just
couldn't do things.
Like I wanted to add navigation
between my tweets,
and I have to wait for
Twitter to do that.
BRETT SLATKIN: Well, and
there's also some bad
examples, too.
So there's cases where you want
it to be more custom or
more flexible, but there's also
cases that I know of of
data loss or even losing
your content.
Could you talk about
those a little bit?
TANTEK CELIK: So on the sadder
side of why a lot of folks
come to the indie web is they
build up a whole site, a
community, a something, on
someone else's site, and then
it gets shut down, oftentimes
with very little notice,
oftentimes with no easy way
to download your content.
Sometimes you can download your
content, sometimes, but I
think Posterous is sort of
the most recent example.
And this seems to be a
cycle that repeats
almost every year.
Large company acquires smaller
company, all the content.
And then within a year or
two, the content and the
URLs are all lost.
So it's one of those downsides
of whenever you go and you put
your content on someone else's
site, we call that
sharecropping.
Certainly the same practices
of trying to actually grow
your crops on someone
else's land.
You actually don't have
control over it.
BRETT SLATKIN: And then
how about identity?
What are some cases of the
problems that happen with
identity in the indie web?
TANTEK CELIK: So one of the
things with buying a domain
name is it's pretty much yours
unless some company comes by
and says, hey, we have a
trademark on that name.
We're going to take it.
And then you're sort
of dealing with the
broader legal system.
But with accounts on any
random system, the site
provider, the social network,
whatever, can decide to give
away your account or to lock
it for any reason.
They all have very different
terms of services.
They essentially amount to
you don't own anything.
We control everything.
We can do whatever we want.
So a lot of people have either
lost or had their identities
even reassigned.
BRETT SLATKIN: And
there's really no
recourse when that happens?
TANTEK CELIK: There's basically
no legal recourse,
because you agreed to their
terms of service which let
them do whatever they want.
That's what all the
terms of services
essentially come down to.
Some of them are a little bit
better about that, like
Flickr's long time had
a really good--
you own your content.
We don't claim any rights to
it or something like that.
And it would be nice if there
were more sites that did that,
but in general, sites sort of
err on the side of, no, we own
everything, and you're just
kind of playing in our
playground because we're letting
you do it for free.
BRETT SLATKIN: So that's kind
of more of the worries about
what the indie web solves.
What are some of the positive
things that the indie web
helps with, and what are the
good positive reasons that
people would want to
join the indie web?
TANTEK CELIK: So like many
things, a lot of these
frustrations turned into sort
of the mother of invention.
Like you go, you're like, OK, I
want to build my own thing,
because I'm frustrated with what
the service is offering
me or not offering me.
And you start doing that, and
you realize, wow, I actually
have so much more freedom here
to do amazing things, like I'm
not limited to 140 characters.
I can start embedding images in
line, JPEGs, and movies or
whatever, in a much
better way than
Twitter does it, or whatever.
I can provide a better user
interface, a cleaner user
interface than what
Twitter does.
BRETT SLATKIN: And for user
interface, you mean your
readers, the people who consume
what you create.
TANTEK CELIK: That's right.
So on my site, at tantek.com, I
can post a video, and I can
post an image, I can post a
series of them, and it'll show
up like interspersed
in my content.
And I think I can provide a much
cleaner experience for
people to come to read my
content there than on Twitter
and all the other sites, where
you see lists of suggested
followers or here are some other
ads you might check, or
maybe use this promoted account
or all this noise.
It seems like every content silo
eventually deteriorates
into something like that, where
you're just surrounded
by all of this distraction
around the actual content.
BRETT SLATKIN: Yeah, so you have
control over the way it
looks and feels.
TANTEK CELIK: The experience.
BRETT SLATKIN: The experience.
That's great.
TANTEK CELIK: That's a really
big thing for me.
The personal expression's
a big one.
I get to alter the design
however I feel like.
BRETT SLATKIN: So are there any
other examples of positive
things that come from that?
I mean, so you get
to customize.
But what are some
other positives?
TANTEK CELIK: So we talked
about sites going away.
In fact, we have a whole page on
site deaths, where we have
a chronology of different sites
that have shut down, how
many people's accounts have
lost, links have been lost.
If you own your own
domain, it's like
owning your own phone.
As long as you're paying the
bills, you've got that domain
name and you've got your
content there.
BRETT SLATKIN: You mean like
phone number, like a portable
phone number.
TANTEK CELIK: Right.
BRETT SLATKIN: You could go
between providers, and nobody
can take it away from you.
TANTEK CELIK: Right, so just
like you can port your phone
number between providers, you
can port your domain between
web hosting services.
And you'll pay someone to host
it there, some trivial amount,
less than it costs to have
a phone, a lot less.
But we put so much energy into
so much of this content we
create for the web, and yet we
don't sort of back it up with
even a fraction of what
we do for just
having a phone number.
BRETT SLATKIN: Yeah,
that's interesting.
So I've been to IndieWebCamp.
I'm going again this year, and I
wanted to talk about some of
the things that people hack
on at IndieWebCamp.
So two of the examples that I
know about are these kind of
funny terms.
There's POSSE and PESOS, so I
thought I'd talk about that
real quick.
The thing is, in the indie web,
if you make content on
your own site and you publish it
on your own site, you still
want to engage with
your audience.
And you want to push what you've
created to Twitter and
Facebook and Google+ and on and
on, because you want as
big of an audience
as possible.
You're writing content to be
read in a lot of ways.
TANTEK CELIK: Sure.
BRETT SLATKIN: But the question
is, how do you engage
with your audience without
losing control?
And so POSSE and PESOS
are two of the ways I
know of doing that.
I was just going to
say what they are.
The first one, POSSE, is Publish
On your own Site,
Syndicate Elsewhere.
So this is where you
have your blog.
You publish to it, and then you
tweet out a link or share
a link on Facebook that
people can find.
The second one is PESOS, where
you actually publish somewhere
else and then suck all
the content back
into your own site.
There's a bunch of tools that'll
do this now, so you
can just engage all
over the place.
But then almost like a personal
archive, it'll bring
everything back to your site so
there's one place to find
everything.
So then what are some other
examples of things that people
hack on at IndieWebCamp?
What can we expect?
TANTEK CELIK: So I think a lot
of it really comes from the
core value of because it's your
own site, because you're
putting your own stuff out there
and you're building on
it, that's something we
call self-dog fooding.
There's this concept of dog
fooding that we have in the
industry of eating your own dog
food, like whatever you
create, working on it.
And it's oftentimes applied to
companies, where a company
will have an API, and so they'll
build on top of their
own API to make sure that the
API actually works properly.
But we've introduced this notion
of self-dog fooding,
where it's like it's not just
you and your company, but you
with yourself.
And I think once you start doing
that, you realize, oh,
my priorities for what I want to
do are very different than
if I was just building a product
for some person.
Because I want to own
my own content.
I want to control it.
But yet I still want to stay
in touch with my friends.
And that's really where POSSE
came from, was this diligent
desire to own your own content,
but then like, hey,
my friends are reading it on
Twitter, or my friends are
reading it on Facebook, or my
friends are reading it on
Google Reader.
Wherever they're reading, you're
like, OK, I have to
have a feed if someone's
using a feed reader.
Or if someone's just using
Twitter, I need to post copies
of my content to Twitter
or Facebook.
But in all those cases, one
thing we've tried to do is
make sure that there's always
links or some identifier
pointing back to the original.
And that's important, because
when you start kind of forking
these conversations in these
different forums, you may want
to actually integrate them back
in your own site, and
somebody might want to see
the whole story of
what's going on.
BRETT SLATKIN: Yeah,
that makes sense.
TANTEK CELIK: So that's kind
of what drove POSSE.
And what's kind of interesting
is that the indie web efforts
really have built on a lot
of previous efforts like
federated social web, things
like that, that were looking
to create a giant distributed
social network of different
sites and things.
But when we all took an
independent individual
approach to it--
so the word "indie" sort of
has double meanings here--
it turns out that the priorities
really change from,
oh, Federation, to, no,
we want to stay in
touch with our friends.
A lot of that comes
down to that.
And we talk about readers
and audience.
But a lot of the folks on the
indie web are doing it purely
as hobbyists, as independents,
not necessarily as a business.
Although, sure, if you want
to do it as a business,
it makes sense too.
You should own your own site.
BRETT SLATKIN: Right.
So then the range of projects
that we're going to see--
I mean, it's a lot of hobbyists
and amateurs, in
some ways non-professional
reasons to do it.
It's labors of love--
that kind of thing.
I was thinking what are a couple
of examples of that?
I know that RelMeAuth was a
big thing last year, Indie
Comments are another thing
kind of this year.
Maybe you could tell us a little
bit about RelMeAuth and
Indie Comments.
TANTEK CELIK: Sure.
So RelMeAuth arose out of
a need to do independent
identity with URLs, and so
there's a standard called
OpenID that kind of solved this
problem, did a great job,
there's a lot of deployments
out there.
And you can set up your own site
to be your identifier and
log in to all of these different
sites using OpenID.
Now, the challenge is that on
the indie web, everyone's sort
of a small scrappy developer,
because they're all developing
themselves.
And so if you want to consume
an OpenID, it's
actually a lot of work.
BRETT SLATKIN: It's
very difficult.
TANTEK CELIK: It's
really difficult.
A lot of us have tried
and looked at the
libraries and gave up.
We were like, this is
just too much work.
There's got to be
an easier way.
Since OpenID, things like
Twitter Sign In came up,
Facebook Connect, all these silo
specific sources came up.
BRETT SLATKIN: And even OpenID
Connect, which is a
simplification of OpenID,
because they realized that
there were some issues
with the way--
TANTEK CELIK: They tried to come
out too, but that didn't
really take off.
Twitter and Facebook really
raised the bar, in terms of it
should be this easy to integrate
sign on, so third
party delegated sign
on to your site.
So we were like, OK,
that's good.
That's a good bar to set.
So with RelMe, we have a way
of connecting your site to
your Twitter account, or your
site to your GitHub account.
And from there, what we do is
we say, hey, we'll use your
site as your identity, but since
you're delegating your
authentication to GitHub,
we'll use GitHub's OAuth
support that they already
have built in.
BRETT SLATKIN: And all
their security that
comes with that, yeah.
TANTEK CELIK: And all their
security that comes with that
to authenticate you.
So you kind of get the
best of both worlds.
We're going to keep
track of you as--
what's your domain again?
Big Fluke?
BRETT SLATKIN: One
Big Fluke, yeah.
TANTEK CELIK: One Big
Fluke, that's right.
.com.
But whenever you log in, we're
going to authenticate you
using whatever providers you
happen to provide at that
point in time.
So that's how RelMeAuth started
is sort of like a
simpler version of OpenID like
work that people could consume
that was much easier
to implement.
BRETT SLATKIN: That's great.
And then what about the
new IndieWeb Comments?
TANTEK CELIK: So IndieWeb
Comments are kind of a
fascinating rebirth from
an effort that was
about 10 years ago.
So about 10 years ago, Ian
Hickson developed and wrong
this spec called Pingback.
And it kind of was the evolution
of a lot of efforts
like Trackback, of blogs talking
to blogs, and trying
to include excerpts or be like,
hey, I linked to you.
Here's the pingback.
But it never really solved
the comment problem.
And by the comment problem, I
mean if you want to comment on
a blog, you have to go to that
blog, you have to sign into
that blog, you have to type
a comment on that blog.
And then it's kind of there.
It's like a dead end.
Or there are services now that
do this with JavaScript too, a
bunch of them.
But that just means they
don't get indexed.
So we wanted to solve this.
We were like, well, no, if I
write a blog post, if another
person wants to comment on it
like on the indie web, they
should write their comment
on their own site and
then send it to me.
And then I'll syndicate it and
show it just as good as if
someone had written the
comment natively.
BRETT SLATKIN: That reminds me
a lot of the Tumblr model,
where you reblog something
and then add your
little bit to it.
TANTEK CELIK: Yes, very
similar to that.
It's very similar to
the Tumblr model.
BRETT SLATKIN: But it's
distributed, so anyone can do
it from any site.
TANTEK CELIK: Yes, that's the
biggest difference there.
And we were basically working
through the pieces of how to
make this work.
There's a simplified version of
Pingback called Webmention
that uses just pure
HTTP, essentially.
There's no XML or PC in there.
That's great.
And then the other big piece
really came down to
presentation.
So to make a comment look good,
I'd say if there's one
big distinguishing feature in
addition to self-dog fooding
of the indie web versus sort
of previous efforts is that
we're all focused on making our
sites look good and feel
good, because it's
our own site.
BRETT SLATKIN: And there's
a lot of designers in the
community too, so it
seems like it's--
TANTEK CELIK: We're a much
more designer-friendly
community, for sure.
So with comments are
the same problem.
We're like, OK, you bring up
someone's comment post, and
we've got to make those comments
look just right.
What does that mean?
We need the content
of the comment.
We need the permalink
We need an avatar
for the person.
We need a link to their site.
We need a date and time stamp.
We need all these things, which
it turns out we actually
have all that with
Microformats.
So people publishing this on
their web page in HTML, just
adding a few simple
Microformats--
hEntry, hCard, saying, hey, this
entry is here and here is
the hCard author of it--
all we had to do is actually
add one rel value,
in-reply-to, so that you could
link to the thing you're
commenting on and say,
rel=in-reply-to, this is a
comment in reply to this post.
And by doing that, it made it
so that it was discoverable.
And then the person posting the
comment just sends a web
mention to the original post
and says, hey, by the way--
just like Pingback--
I mentioned you, but this is
actually a reply, a comment.
The guy's site goes back and
says, OK, let me read your
permalink that you claim
is a comment, see if
you're linking to me.
Oh, you are, with
rel-in-reply-to, cool.
Let me get to contents
of your comment.
Oh, let me get your avatar.
Great, now I can display it as
if it was a native comment on
my own site.
BRETT SLATKIN: That's great.
TANTEK CELIK: And that
just happened.
BRETT SLATKIN: It
was very recent.
TANTEK CELIK: Less than
two months ago.
BRETT SLATKIN: Yeah.
And how many sites are doing
kind of the IndieWeb Comment?
TANTEK CELIK: So I have to
actually look at the site,
because when it started,
I blogged--
BRETT SLATKIN: Obviously,
two was the beginning.
And then it was three very
quickly after that, and yeah,
what are we up to now?
TANTEK CELIK: So within minutes,
the first comment
showed up, and it worked.
And it was kind of like magic,
because the guy writing the
comment didn't know it
was going to work.
And then there's follow up
commentary, and within a few
days there were four people.
BRETT SLATKIN: Yeah,
four people.
TANTEK CELIK: From four
different countries.
BRETT SLATKIN: Right,
and totally separate
implementations as well.
TANTEK CELIK: Belgium, the
US, France, England--
totally separate
implementations, different sites.
And the funny thing is, none
of them from the Bay Area.
That was the other thing.
BRETT SLATKIN: That's cool.
TANTEK CELIK: It's like
indie web is such
a distributed thing.
But now if you look at it,
there's let's see.
So this says four.
BRETT SLATKIN: A lot.
And you expect more this
weekend, I mean, after this
coming weekend at the
IndieWebCamp.
TANTEK CELIK: Six, seven--
so we're up to seven different
implementations.
BRETT SLATKIN: Right, and I
think out of this weekend at
IndieWebCamp, next weekend,
hopefully
we'll get a lot more.
Because that's kind of what
happens is a lot of
hacking and so on.
TANTEK CELIK: Yeah, yeah, in
fact, Ben Werdmuller is the
first one in the Bay Area to
actually join in this thread.
BRETT SLATKIN: OK, to actually
employ that.
TANTEK CELIK: And this
commentary thread on
[? Eshnu's ?]
blog, where he literally just
started with saying, testing,
IndieWeb Federation.
And then he--
BRETT SLATKIN: And it worked.
TANTEK CELIK: He at mentioned a
few folks, which works over
the indie web.
And then a bunch of people
started commenting on it, and
now it's become this kind
of proving ground.
When you've got commenting
working on your site, you kind
of go leave a comment on his
original post, testing this.
So you can kind of see a
chronology of who got what
working when.
It's very exciting.
BRETT SLATKIN: Yeah,
it's exciting.
Oh, yeah, so this other thing.
So there are more spaces.
Before we go, there's a few more
spaces at IndieWebCamp
next weekend, June 22 to 23.
TANTEK CELIK: Eight, there's
eight spots left.
BRETT SLATKIN: In Portland,
Oregon.
So if you are around and have
the time, please come and sign
up at indiewebcamp.com.
You can find Tantek online
at tantek.com.
You can find me online
at onebigfluke.com.
And thanks very much
for watching.